my vibe on the sexy Santa thing think
it's cool it's not really my thing
Santa's just not not a sexy thing
there's some men and women out there
that are super kinky and into some weird
it's just like jolly old man that comes
down chimneys and gives little children
presents and then you want that same
person without a beard laning your bed
rate of that's kind of strange I don't
think that trying on sexy Santa office
is gonna ruin my perception of Santa but
it might ruin some other people's
perception of Santa we got oh God
oh all right this is like a Borat Santa
with a hoodie so that goes like that
okay you gotta have the quintessential
hat all right let's do this
there we go
you know I was gonna go for it I was
gonna show the world my little baby but
I'll be honest he was just falling out
and I had to wear underwear under it
this is not made for a male genitalia
and I didn't have the balls to wear this
ass out sorry everyone this is trash
this is a word I'd say I feel really
trashy but I like that I can show off my
chest tattoo the nipples being exposed I
thought I would like not actually into
it I just don't feel sexy I feel a
little trashy I think that this could be
fun for like a couple get married around
Christmas a wife her husband and wants
to surprise their wife or husband it
really wants me to have like a certain
figure that I'm just kind of like
busting out of right now but if I found
someone really cared about them this was
their thing I could see this being like
on their birthdays and Christmas type of
thing I'd be glad to do for them but uh
this would not be my go to a love that
this goes all the way down and lead to
you know the treasure this outfit could
be higher-quality it's this is really
just a one and done one time where we're
looking for real lasting sexy Santa
experience maybe leather or latex I
think the market on sexy Santa for men
lingerie has not been cornered and we
should really dive in there and make it
to thing a lumbersexual czar really hot
right now and you've got the dad bod you
combine those two and you basically have
Santa but he's good with kids and he's
married for a long time we never heard
about him like cheated on and mrs. Claus
so he's like the ideal man to all those
boys and girls out there in the magical
world of YouTube or wherever you're
watching this Merry Christmas to you and
your family share this with everyone let
them know the joy that Santa can bring
[Music]